PROFESSOR: OK, so what I want
to do today is to finish up
the lecture that we were engaged
with last week about
utilitarianism and then to move
on to what is perhaps the
most dead-guy-on-Tuesday lecture
of the semester, that
is, an explanation of the
philosophy of Immanuel Kant.
So in order to make up for the
fact that the second part of
the lecture is fairly dry, we'll
have a couple of clicker
questions in the first
part of the lecture.
OK, so as you recall from our
lecture last class, John
Stuart Mill, in the selections
from Utilitarianism that we
read, says two extraordinarily
famous things that serve in
some ways as the heart of
the utilitarian view.
The first thing that he says is
that he articulates what's
known as the greatest
happiness principle.
This is a principle that's
supposed to tell you what it
is for an act to be
morally right.
And what Mill says is, there's
a proportionality between the
rightness of the act and
something that it produces.
In particular, a proportionality
between the
rightness of the act and the
amount of happiness it
produces, regardless of how that
happiness is distributed.
In particular he says "actions
are right in proportion as
they tend to promote happiness,
they're wrong as
they tend to promote the reverse
of happiness," and the
happiness with which we're
concerned is not the agent's
own happiness but "the happiness
of all concerned."
The second extraordinarily
famous saying that he says in
the opening passages of
Utilitarianism is that the
motive with which an act is
performed is irrelevant to the
act's moral worth.
He says the motive has nothing
to do with the
morality of the action.
"He who saves another creature
from drowning does what is
morally right, whether his
motive be duty or the hope of
being paid for it."
So we might summarize what
these principles say, as
saying that the first one tells
us that what matters for
the morality of an act is the
aggregate amount of happiness
that it produces.
And what we're concerned with
here are aggregates, not
individuals.
We're interested in how much
good is done overall, not
where those pieces of good
might happen to fall.
And what the second principle
tells us is that what the
utilitarian, who is after all
a consequentialist, is
concerned with are
consequences.
They're interested in the
outcome of the act, not the
process by which that outcome
was achieved.
So the first reading that we
did for last class was a
selection from Mill's
Utilitarianism where he
articulated these principles.
And it's important to recognize
that these get
something profoundly right
about what we're thinking
about, I think, when we try to
articulate what lies behind
our moral judgment.
It does seem right that what
we're interested in is what
the world is like after a
particular action is taken,
and to the extent that we're
interested in what the world
is like, our primary interest
is not in how that state of
affairs came about, but what
that state of affairs is.
And our primary concern, if
we're taking a moral stance,
is not in how much we ourselves
have, but rather in
how much good there is
in the world overall.
That said, there have been,
since utilitarianism was
articulated, a classic set of
objections which are raised to
the view, some of which we'll
talk more about today, and
some of which we encountered in
the selection from Bernard
Williams that we read
last class.
Now you will all recall that
Williams' discussion begins
with a story of a gentleman that
he calls Jim, who finds
himself in a South American
village that's run by a rather
unsavory cowboy.
And some of the citizens of
that village have been
protesting the unsavory
cowboy's leadership.
And so what the unsavory cowboy
has done is he has
rounded up twenty of those
villagers, and he's
planning--simply to show the
others that he's in charge--to
kill those twenty villagers.
When Jim arrives, Pedro the
cowboy tells him that, if Jim
is willing to shoot one of the
villagers, the other nineteen
will be set free.
So that's the Jim case.
Jim shows up in a town.
The sheriff of the town has
selected twenty people at
random to be shot, but if Jim is
willing to kill one of them
the other 19 will be
set free, so--
clickers out--
Question: In the Jim
case, what is Jim
morally obliged to do?
Is the moral thing for Jim to
do in this case to shoot the
one man, thereby liberating the
other nineteen, or is the
right thing for him to do to
refuse to shoot the one,
thereby letting all
twenty die?
OK, so let's see how the
numbers came out.
So almost 3/4 of you, actually
more than 3/4 of you, think
that what the morally right
thing for Jim to do in this
case is to shoot one
man, thereby
liberating the other nineteen.
We'll have a chance next week
to talk a lot in about these
sorts of questions.
Our reading for Thursday is a
series of moral dilemmas with
this structure.
But what I want to ask those
77% of you, who answered
"yes," to do now is to think
about whether you take what
Williams says is the natural
utilitarian next step.
Williams argues that if you are
a committed utilitarian,
and you think that the morally
right thing for Jim to do is
to shoot the one and release the
other nineteen, then you
ought to feel no moral
compunction about doing so.
There's a clear right
thing to do.
The right thing is to
kill the one, so
it's to save the nineteen.
You may feel moral
disapprobation--indeed you
should feel moral
disapprobation--towards Pedro
who put Jim in this situation.
But you ought to feel no moral
disapprobation towards Jim,
and even more importantly
according to Williams, Jim
himself ought to feel no
moral compunction.
So among the 77% of you who
answered that Jim did the
right thing in killing the one
and saving the nineteen, do
you think that in shooting the
one man, Jim ought to think of
any hesitation that he feels
as mere squeamishness,
something that ought
to be overcome?
Or do you think that Jim ought
to think of the hesitation
that he feels in doing what the
utilitarian and in what
you yourself said was the right
thing, do you think he
ought to think of his hesitation
as being indicative
of something morally relevant?
So there's roughly seventy
of you who should
be answering this.
Let's see how the numbers
come out.
OK, so most of you take
on only part of the
consequentialist picture here,
at least in the way that
Williams understands it.
Most of you think that, although
the right thing for
Jim to do in that case is to
kill the one to save the
nineteen, it's not the case that
he ought wholeheartedly
to endorse that as the
right thing to do.
In a minute, I'm going to
present to you Williams'
analogy to the case of residual
racism to try to help
you see why someone who really
has taken on board the
consequentialist outlook thinks
that the combination of
views which most of you present,
where you think the
right thing to do is to kill the
one to save the nineteen,
but you also think the right
thing to do is to feel bad
about that in some way, have not
fully appreciated what the
utilitarian stance provides
you with as a way of
understanding morality.
So Williams, as you know,
presents us with two cases.
The first is the case that I've
just given you, the case
of Jim and the captive
Indians.
The second is the case in high
'70's fashion of a man who is
needing to go back to work
because it's difficult to have
his wife working outside
of the home.
I leave that to you
as a period piece.
But the work which George is
provided in Williams' example
is work in a bioweapons lab,
something to which George
feels moral opposition.
But if George doesn't take the
job in the bioweapons lab a
much more gung-ho person,
somebody who's likely to
advocate the use of bioweapons
in all sorts of contexts, will
get the job instead.
So the two cases that Williams
presents us with there have a
common structure.
And a common structure which
we're going to see again and
again in moral dilemmas.
There's one act that the person
can do that leads to a
particular outcome, another
act that the person can do
that leads to a different
outcome, where the first act
is worse on its surface
than the second.
So Jim has the possibility of
shooting one person, or
shooting no people.
Those are the choices
that Jim faces.
If Jim does the first act,
shooting one person, then
nineteen people will go free;
if Jim does the second act,
which is not to shoot anybody
at all, to refuse Pedro's
bargain, then all twenty
people will be shot.
Likewise, George faces a choice
between doing one
thing, taking the job in--
sorry, George faces the choice
between taking the job in the
bio lab and not taking the
job in the bio lab.
If George takes the job in the
bio lab, then the gung-ho
biological weapons fellow
won't [will]
get the job, and the outcome
will be better [worse].
If George doesn't take the
job, then the gung-ho
biological weapons person won't
get the job and the
outcome will be better.
So, in both cases we have an
act killing the one versus
killing none, taking the job
versus not taking the job,
which is worse than another, but
the outcomes of those acts
are inverted.
The consequentialist tells us
not to look at the act side of
the equation, but
to look at the
outcome side of the equation.
The only things, says the
consequentialist, that we need
to take into consideration, is
how many people are saved or
how much bio-weapons
research is done.
According to the
consequentialist, what we do
is we look and we see, outcome
one is better than outcome
two, and then reading back from
that, we decide which
thing we ought to do.
We ought to do act one because
it's the thing that produces
the better outcome.
The deontologist or virtue
ethicist says, not so fast.
Don't jump straight to the
consequence, look also at what
it is that is needed to be
done by the individual to
bring about that consequence.
And recognizing that act one
is worse than act two, the
deontologist or virtue ethicist
says, it's at least
important to take seriously as
a possibility that the right
thing to do in this situation is
the second act, even if the
outcome that it leads
to is worse.
Now what Williams points out is
that if one takes seriously
the first of these stances,
the one where what we're
looking at is the outcome and
not the process which gave
rise to that outcome, then any
hesitation we feel towards
bringing about that outcome as
the result of that particular
act is due to what we might
call a certain kind of
squeamishness.
The utilitarian says, and we
started with the quotes from
Mill for this reason, that
thinking about who does an act
is morally irrelevant, just as
thinking about who gets the
goods is morally irrelevant.
What matters, says the greatest
happiness principle,
is how much aggregate happiness
is produced; what
matters not, except in so far
as it affects the amount of
happiness, is who produces that
happiness or where that
happiness goes.
So there is room on the
consequentialist picture for
second-order thinking about the
distributions of happiness.
If gross inequities in the
amount of happiness across a
society produces itself less
happiness, then we can take
that into consideration
in our calculus.
If performing a particular kind
of act produces in an
individual less happiness,
we can take that into
consideration in our calculus.
But ultimately the only things
that go into the equation in
determining whether an act is
morally right is the amount of
happiness and not where that
happiness is distributed.
Now, as Epictetus pointed out,
some things are up to us and
some things are not up to us.
And when Jim arrives in Pedro's
village, one of the
things that is not up to him
is the fact that he faces a
forced choice of the structure
that Pedro has
presented him with.
It goes without saying that
what Pedro has done is
outrageous, but the structure
of the situation that Jim
confronts is a very
simple one.
Either Pedro will kill twenty
people or Jim will kill one
person and the other nineteen
will not die.
That's what's there for
Jim to be deciding on.
Nonetheless, 75% of the 75% of
you who thought that Jim did
the right thing in that
situation think that Jim ought
to feel some squeamishness about
carrying out that act.
What Williams points out is that
if one takes seriously
the consequentialist picture,
then perhaps the morally right
thing to do is to try to
cultivate in oneself moral
sentiments that accord with
one's moral judgments.
If through rational
argumentation and reflection
you come to realize of yourself
that--although you
are committed to racial
equality, although you are
committed to gender equality,
although you are committed to
equality regardless of gender
identification, you're
committed to not being ageist,
you're committed to not being
discriminatory on the basis of
physical disability--you
might, as a result of having
lived in a society largely
structured in ways that encode
a kind of residual racism and
sexism and homophobia, you might
find in yourself certain
sentiments that lead you
instantaneously to respond in
ways that run contrary to what
your moral commitments tell
you you ought to do.
In those cases, I take it you
think that there's some moral
mandate upon you to
try to get rid of
those instinctive responses.
If you're really committed to
anti-racism, then you want to
the extent possible to have a
harmonious soul when engaging
in interracial encounters.
If your reason tells you that
you're committed to
anti-racism, you want your
spirit and appetite to be in
line in that way.
So there are instances where
morality on reflection tells
us that something is right, and
the consequence of that
for our behavior towards
ourselves is that we ought to
try to cultivate in ourselves
instincts that
correspond to that.
Williams says the utilitarian
should say that in cases like
the Jim case, Jim is like the
residual racist. He knows what
the right thing to do is, but he
has a residual tendency to
be pulled in the morally
wrong direction.
If you don't think that it's
true that Jim ought to change
his attitudes in that case,
and you do think that the
residual implicit racist ought
to try to change her attitude,
it would be useful to try to
think about what holds those
two cases apart.
OK, so that's what I want to
say in closing about the
utilitarianism and
it's critics.
And we'll return as I said to
those issues twice more, once
on Thursday when we read Judy
Thomson's trolley problem
paper and once next Tuesday when
we look at some empirical
work on that question, which
suggests a naturalistic
explanation for why it
is that Jim feels the
hesitation that he does.
What I want to do now is to
introduce you to the third of
all the main moral outlooks that
we're going to consider
this semester.
So last lecture we looked very
carefully at consequentialist
moral theories in the form of
John Stuart Mill, and those
are theories which locate the
moral value of an act in its
consequences.
In the first part of the class
we spent a lot of time looking
at Aristotle's virtue theory,
which located the moral worth
of an act in the actor.
Remember we looked at acts
having more worth only if
they're done as the result
of a sort of
constancy of character.
What we're going to look at
today is the third piece of
this story, of a moral view
that says the morality
attached to an action is not the
result of what the actor
is like, it's not the result of
what the consequences are
like, rather it is about
the act itself.
In particular, we're going to
look at the deontological
theory of Immanuel Kant.
So, Immanuel Kant was an 18th
century German philosopher
who, like Plato and Aristotle,
provided a comprehensive and
systematic philosophical theory
that to this day is
taken seriously as one of the
ways one might make sense of
the world as a whole.
Kant has theories of
metaphysics, that is, what
kind of stuff there is.
He has theories of epistemology,
that is, how we
know about what kind
of stuff there is.
He has theories of ethics, what
the right thing to do is.
And he has theories of
aesthetics, that is, what
gives things aesthetic value.
Famously, Kant articulated his
views about the three major
domains of philosophy three
enormous and dense books: the
first, The Critique of Pure
Reason, which told you about
what the world is like and how
we know it to be that way,
which he wrote first in 1781 and
then revised; the second,
The Critique of Practical
Reason, which is an account of
the nature of morality; and
the third, The Critique of
Judgment, which is an account
of the nature
of aesthetic value.
But in addition to those dense
works Kant also wrote what he
took to be more popular
presentations of his view.
In the case of metaphysics,
he wrote a book called The
Prolegomena to any Future
Metaphysics.
And in the case of ethics, he
wrote something that he calls
the Grounding for the
Metaphysics of Morals, which
is of course the work
from which we read
excerpts for today.
So I give you this context
because I want you to know
that, as hard as the reading
that we did from Kant was, I
chose for you perhaps the
easiest part of the easiest
book that he wrote.
So, what should you take home
from Kant if you take home
nothing else?
If you take home nothing else
from our reading of Kant, I
want you to take home Kant's
idea of the categorical
imperative.
And my goal in the remainder of
lecture today is to bring
you, by reading through with you
the text of Kant that we
had today, to a point where you
will be well positioned to
understand what Kant means by
the categorical imperative.
And depending on how the next
twenty minutes go, we'll get
to that either right at the
end of today's lecture or
right at the beginning
of Thursday's.
OK, so Kant's text, the
Grounding for the Metaphysics
of Morals begins with a very
famous passage where Kant
says, "nothing can be regarded
as good without qualification
except the good will." This
claim should be familiar to
you, O readers of Book II
of Plato's The Republic.
This is the classic distinction
between things
that have intrinsic value and
things that are merely of
instrumental worth.
And indeed much in the way that
Plato's Socrates does,
Kant goes on to enumerate some
things which fall into the
other category, the category
of things that are of mere
instrumental utility.
Among the things that cannot
be regarded as good without
qualification, says Kant, are
talents of the mind like
intelligence and wit, qualities
of temperament like
courage and perseverance, gifts
of fortune like power
and riches and honor
and health.
And he says, taking a direct
gibe at Aristotle, and noting
as such that he's so doing,
neither can the ancient
virtues--(oh, my goodness,
how do I close that
email?)--neither can the ancient
virtues of moderation
and self control be considered
as good in themselves.
Why?
Because though being
intelligent, or brave, or
rich, or controlled, will help
you to achieve the goals that
you have, they don't determine
what those goals might be.
They magnify your effectiveness
as an agent, but
they don't determine
the valence, the
value of your agency.
So, says Kant, a witty,
persevering, rich, healthy,
moderate thief will be an
outstanding thief--but that
doesn't make his
thiefdom good.
Each of the virtues that has
traditionally been extolled as
a virtue, says Kant, gains its
value only in so far as the
good will is part of it.
Now a good will, says Kant, is
good not because of what it
affects or accomplishes,
it's good in itself.
When I say that Kant is a critic
of consequentialism I
am not exaggerating.
Kant doesn't think that
the outcome of
the act is what matters.
And in an extraordinarily famous
passage, famous in part
because of the rather shocking
translation which has come
down to us of it, Kant says,
"the good will would remain
good, even if by the niggardly
provision of step-motherly
nature it wholly lacked the
power to accomplish its
purpose." By which he means,
even if you with your good
will were frustrated in all of
the goals that you set out to
achieve, your actions would
still have moral worth.
And somewhat more poetically and
a bit less vocabulary that
is challenging to the modern
ear, Kant says, even if it
didn't achieve its outcome "it
would like a jewel still shine
by its own light as something
which has
full value in itself.
Its usefulness or fruitlessness
can neither
augment nor its value."
Now the question is this:
How could anybody come
to have this view?
How could anybody have a view
of morality that says, what
matters for an act to be moral
is not the outcome that it
produces, but rather the
description under which the
act is done?
What I want to try to do right
now is to put you inside the
Kantian picture so that you
get a sense of what that
worldview looks like.
So in the passages that we read
for today, Kant makes
three particular claims. He says
that an action must be
done from duty in order
to have moral worth.
The first notion that I want to
try to explicate for you is
the Kantian notion of something
being done from duty.
An action done from duty,
says Kant in his second
proposition, has its moral worth
not in the purpose that
is to be attained by it, but
in the maxim according to
which the action
is determined.
So the way that an action done
from duty has more worth is
not by looking to see what
outcome you're expecting from
it, but rather by looking
to see under what
characterization did you
perform the act.
And again, I'll spell out what
each of those terms mean.
Finally, says Kant, duty, which
lies at the heart of
deontological moral theory,
"duty is the necessity of an
action done out of the respect
for the law." Kant believes
that it is only when you subject
your will to a law
which you have made for
yourself--that is, the moral
law whose binding force upon you
you have recognized--it is
only in that circumstance
that you are truly free.
So Kant says, "duty is the
necessity of an action done
out of the respect for the law,"
and when you perform an
action out of respect for the
moral law, says Kant, then and
only then do you act
autonomously.
OK, so three, incredibly
complicated,
subtle claims from Kant.
Let's try getting to the bottom
of what they mean.
So let's start with the first
claim, the claim that an act
has moral worth only when
it is done from duty.
So Kant points out that
there's three kinds of
motivation that we might have
in performing an act.
We might do an act out of duty,
we might do it out of
inclination, or we might do it
out of self-interest. Only
cases of the first kind, in fact
only pure cases of the
first kind, have moral worth.
Actions that are done merely in
keeping with, but not from
moral duty, have no moral
worth according to Kant.
So if you obey the law but you
do so only out of self
interest, your obedience, says
Kant, has no moral worth.
if you rescue the drowning child
from the pond but you do
so only because there's a sign
on the tree that says, "Rescue
Drowning Children: $1 Million
Reward," your act
has no moral worth.
So we can think about what
Kant's claim amounts to and
how it differs from the other
ones that we've been looking
at by thinking of the
question space in
terms of a flow chart.
So we're trying to decide
whether a particular action
has moral worth, and the first
thing we want to ask ourselves
is: "Does the action
accord with duty?
If the answer to that is no,
that is, if you've done
something like lied, or stolen
something, or murdered
somebody, or allowed something
terrible to happen in front of
you that you could have
easily, at no cost to
yourself, prevented, all of the
authors that we've read,
not surprisingly, say that the
act has no moral worth--
Oh so, did that just disappear
that was supposed to
be in red on black?
Is it completely invisible
from the back?
Oh, that's a pity--
OK, so what that says in red
is no lying and stealing--
but it's in red.
I can't change it in the middle
of the slides, but I'll
remind you what those
things say.
OK--
The second question that we
ask, having eliminated now
from the realm of morally worthy
acts those that don't
accord with duty, is: What
motive the act was done with?
So perhaps you act in a morally
worthy way out of
self-interest without immediate
inclinations.
So you pay your taxes because
if you don't pay your taxes
you're going to have
to pay more taxes.
You obey the speed limit but
only because you were afraid
you might get caught
otherwise.
Mill says those acts
have moral worth.
Kant says no, they don't--
And again, that's supposed
to be in red but it's now
invisible--
Suppose that you do an act in
such a way that you have an
inclination that's in
keeping with duty.
So Kant thinks you have a duty
not to commit suicide, and he
considers a case where you fail
to commit suicide because
you're happy.
Kant thinks you need to be loyal
to your life partner,
but he says that there's no
moral worth to remaining loyal
to your life partner while
you are in love.
There's no moral worth, says
Kant, to acting kindly towards
somebody when you feel sympathy
towards them.
Because in those cases, though
your act is in keeping with
what morality demands, it's
not done because it is the
right thing to do.
You are doing it because your
inclination happens to line up
with what morality
demands of you.
Now Aristotle, of course, took
this situation to be the one
in which moral worth is
paradigmatically expressed.
But Kant thinks in such cases
you can not tell that an act
was done from the moral law.
All you can see is that it was
done in keeping with the moral
law, it corresponds to what the
moral law demands, but we
can't see from that that
the motive was duty.
It's only in the third case,
the case where you act from
duty without any inclination and
without any self-interest,
that Kant thinks the
moral worth of an
action can be seen.
If you preserve your life when
you feel the inclination to do
otherwise, if you act kindly in
situations where there's no
reward for you and you feel no
sympathy, in those cases, says
Kant, we can see that the act
was done, not merely in
keeping with, but from
the moral law.
This isn't to say that Kant
doesn't think a life lived in
the way that Aristotle suggested
life is lived is a
badly [well]
lived life.
Cases where your inclination
happens to line up with duty
hopefully keep you out of this
box of doing the wrong thing,
but they don't allow you to test
your character and see of
yourself that the motivation
that you have for doing the
right thing is to conform
to what the moral
law demands of you.
So with that understanding of
what it is to act from duty in
mind, we're now in a position to
make sense of Kant's second
claim in our reading
for today.
Then "an action done from duty
has its moral worth not in the
purpose that's to be obtained
by it, but in the maxim
according to which the action
is determined." So remember
we've learned that an action
done from duty is one that you
do in conformity with what
morality demands, because that
is what morality demands.
Not because it's in your self
interest, not because you were
inclined to behave in that way,
but because that act is
what morality demands of you.
But in order to determine
whether an act is what
morality demands of you, that
act needs to be described in a
particular way to you.
And the way that you describe
that act to yourself makes use
of what Kant calls a maxim,
a subjective principle of
volition--that is, a description
of something that
is about you, the subject,
that's says what your desires
towards behavior are
in that situation.
A subjective principle of
volition, that is, a
description under which
the act is done.
So it takes the form, perhaps:
"In all engagings with all who
come into my shop, I will
provide them with an honest
accounting of how much their
transaction is worth,
regardless of whether I could
be discovered cheating in
this." Or: "In all of my
encounters with those who are
weak and in need of my help, I
will provide them with the aid
that I can regardless of whether
that would be of
benefit to me."
"Only by considering the motive
and not by considering
the outcome can the action be
expressive of the good will
itself." "The good will is the
only thing that is good in
itself," says Kant, and it's
only by looking at the
description under which an act
is done that we can determine
whether the good will was
implicated in the right way in
the choice to perform
that action.
Third claim: "Duty is the
necessity of an action done
out of the respect for the law."
So we know that an act
has moral worth only if
it's done from duty.
We know that in order to be done
from duty it needs to be
done under a certain
description.
And now we're told what it is
that this duty amounts to.
In order for an act to be done
from duty, says Kant, it must
have been done with explicit
recognition that what one is
doing at that point is
respecting the moral law in so
far as it articulates what
morality demands of you.
Not in so far that it
articulates ways that you
might have a well-ordered,
harmonious, happy soul.
Not in so far that it
articulates ways in which lots
of happiness could be spread
around to lots of people.
Out of respect rather, says
Kant, for the fact that it is
what morality demands of you.
The moral worth of an act, says
Kant, does not lie in its
effect, for the effect
could have come
about in multiple ways.
I can set out to release a
biological gas in a subway
that's intended to kill
thousands of people, and
because I'm not very good at
chemistry, the result could be
that I produce an enormous
amount of joy in those
thousands of people.
The effect can come about
in lots of ways.
Kant says Mill would have to say
that in releasing that gas
I have done something
with more worth.
Kant says: No--what matters is
the description under which
the act is done, and in
particular that that
description be that one have
respect for the law itself.
So I told you I was going to
get you to the point of the
categorical imperative, and I
am going to end the lecture
today by bringing you right up
to that point, and then next
class we'll talk about
it in more detail.
So the question is
this, right?
This is a pressing, exciting
question in Kant.
All right, I realize that we're
in the in-Kant part of
things, but this is
really exciting.
"What sort of law...?",
says Kant.
He even puts a "but"
to get you excited.
But, he says--cliffhanger...--
"what sort of law can that be,
the thought of which must
determine the will without
reference to any "intent"
expected effect, so the will can
be called absolutely good
without qualification?"
It's so exciting!
We're finding something that's
going to make us genuinely
autonomous and free and moral!
Well remember: it can't be
anything particular, it can't
be anything specific about the
world or it's outcomes.
What can it be?
It can be the will's universal
conformity of its actions to
law as such!
That is, what makes the law
binding is the fact that it is
recognized by all rational
agents as binding.
In particular, it takes the form
of what Kant calls the
categorical imperative.
And here's the formulation of
the categorical imperative
that we got in our reading for
today: "Never act except in
such a way that I can also will
that my act maxim should
become a universal law." Never
do anything that you couldn't
will everybody else to
do at the same time.
And we'll begin next lecture
with the example that Kant
uses to illustrate this, namely
the lying promise, talk
a little bit more about various
formulations of the
categorical imperative, and then
move to Judy Thomson's
trolley problem paper.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]